[Music]
the patient has lost the ability to
speak he's not deaf and he's technically
not new with the proper amount of care
it's possible that he could regain his
understanding of the world his ability
to speak what's our first course of
action well the state is not going to
pay for any of that so we are going to
put his ass on the first bus downtown
[Music]
get in
take a look at this guy what about him
he's a dead ringer for you it's man
don't look nothing like me I mean look
at him he's too short you can finish the
day for you
I'll take Pronto excuse me Mr Pronto can
I call you latte
latte Pronto latte Pronto is that your
name you and me are gonna do big things
pal and respect bro move move star's
coming through
welcome to your team you got me your
agent got your manager lawyer publicist
Personal Assistant Plus we've got you an
intern
you have got a big film Premiere
tomorrow night does that make you a
little bit nervous
this was a gift from Prince Harry it was
one of the original Knights of the Round
Table sword or something I can't really
remember because I wasn't listening when
he gave it to me
is not ringing don't worry bill I'll get
it back on top I know you think what's
been happening to your careers
accidental everything is by Design
who are you really latte pronto
[Music]
and toy time
I'll get down big time
[Music]
foreign